um on Saturday we put out a video in
regards to the whole H3 H3 versus fnf
stuff right we said yo honestly this
girl's story don't make no sense and so
you know fresh effect came out with
their own little live stream and then
posted a couple of uh you know long form
conversations and I thought it would be
important to cover some of these
receipts see if what we said was correct
it was I don't think I need to place
come on to us we got back to the
apartment and I left my wallet and I
guess it was a gift from God but I left
my wallet in Myron's car because he was
the one driving and Myron gets the
wallet and Walter was like oh he wants
your friend's number if he's gonna bring
back the wallet meaning me
I need your friend's number if I'm gonna
bring back the wallets here we go
okay she asked me what do you say so at
no point in this does he say I need my
key I need your number he ends up going
he ends up going and giving her the keys
okay
so that's the wrong [ __ ] you're a
horrible bum she made up the whole whole
okay you're a hole this whole quid broke
you up you are a whole ass bum my girl
hold up and so this is the second part
this is the part that made me laugh so
remember she's like oh uh I don't know
how to get home all this other stuff
like yeah you know I feel stranded I'm
gonna show y'all how lazy and entitled
these girls are and how close they
actually were where they could have uh
went ahead and gotten it themselves uh
Bureau prisons uh uh to doubt Miami you
guys want to see how [ __ ] lazy these
tricks are one mile
if you don't get the [ __ ] out of here
one month girl my girl my girl my girl
one mile
whoa wow one mile okay everybody got
that on their phone you punching the GPS
boom you gone I'm stranded
you getting up up after these dudes to
get your keys back they're one mile away
do you know how entitled and [ __ ]
lazy you have to be to forget some [ __ ]
after you get a ride from somebody and
to demand that they come deliver to you
they're one mile away
but anyways let's keep playing he's
going to bring back the wallet meaning
me so I was like
um sure like I need my wallet like I'm
not gonna text this guy anyways
um he gets my number and then he try to
maintain a conversation with me like
through text and I was like not
answering him because I had gotten my
wallet back but wait who initiates the
[ __ ] conversation
[Music]
with me so how would I demand to get her
number if she was the one that contacted
me first well right so she's saying oh I
don't I didn't uh I didn't talk with him
I didn't text him back just go play it
through real quick Chris and we're going
to analyze parts of this conversation
pool man shout out to our guy Temple but
look she's not texting me look at that
that looks like a [ __ ] conversation
to me wow okay
that looks like a conversation to me
God damn what are you guys
again I don't like these two
for all intents and purposes Andrew
funnel is a loser that's my personal op
it doesn't matter has no bearing on this
at all
none whatsoever and all these people
like why would you defend these scum I
don't care if they're scum I don't care
if they're Saints did they do what you
claim no then shut the [ __ ] up
that's the end of the story what am I
looking at she's out here claiming all
like he's so desperate and creepy and
all this stuff you out here having
full-on conversations and like you do
and then lying about it in the aftermath
and you want to still be taken as
credible how many lies does somebody
have to tell before you start to look at
them and say why should I believe
anything you say you've already tried to
misrepresent things for your own
personal gain personal gain why should I
believe any part of this story
oh well how about maybe she
misremembered bruh this is a
conversation on text you have records of
this you have time to go send
screenshots to h3h3 to try to expose
this dude but you don't have any records
of these conversations really
get the [ __ ] out of here okay Chris and
me and my friend were saying like you
know it would be fun to sit here and
like make him look dumb like he sits
here and he thinks that he can get all
these women but then a 19 year old like
doesn't like you know like um rejects
him
we brushed over this left this is a hit
piece and that's exactly what the [ __ ] I
told you that there's girls that act
exactly like that I said that that's
what I meant that age we'll go and do
that for ego
because they need to prove some [ __ ]
[ __ ] that was a hundred percent ego
right just to prove something oh you
think you're good you think you're good
perfect that's a hit piece now
this kind of behavior
does not show
whenever they say that you know what
it's only 10 of uh claims that are false
claimed it's a false claim
but it's not reported because
fresh or fit are not going to report
that [ __ ] but things like that happen
because they feel ashamed because it's
Pride because of whatever whatnot
because they need to prove a point
because they dislike someone someone
will do that
we'll do that just because I didn't like
to do so I'm gonna go out of my way to
lie
to create a whole story to do that but
it's not going to be reported reported
why because guys shut the [ __ ] up about
that [ __ ] so whenever you come and talk
to me about false claims that are
reported it's only that shut the [ __ ] up
about that [ __ ] because that [ __ ] is not
real
I just want to appreciate something we
glanced over this last time but just
think of how manipulative and how much
of a [ __ ] loser you have to be to
despise someone go out of your way to
interact with this person so you can
then afterwards reject them so you want
to lead somebody on pretend you have
interest so you can be like you [ __ ]
loser you wanted me get out of here I
would never how much of a loser you have
to be to go out of your way to spend
time with people you apparently
so
um basically he kept like texting me
every day she goes uh okay I only if
only we didn't have plans for the day I
can ask Isabella to text him too okay
don't sweat it what time are you uh guys
done with your day stuff I'm thinking
sometime around seven or eightish okay
uh and then I respond oh she sends me
that at 1 22 PM I don't send her
anything she sends me a message the next
day 2 52 a.m you should add the Jeopardy
song to the soundboard
no he's texting me I hate your show so
bad but here's a tip uh to make it
better because you know I hate it so bad
so it would be better if you
give
my brother Russell well I don't get mad
about this though I just think what a
loser what [ __ ] losers and you know
what it is [ __ ] loser you know what
it is you're abominable okay I'm gonna
tell you guys two things one there's
people who take a tremendous amount of
pride in rejecting people I
absolutely absolute dweeps I remember
one time I shot my shot with this grown
person she said no I said cool have a
good day come to find out she went and
told half the people in her community
did she rejected I was like why don't
you tell people I asked you on a date he
said no let's keep it pushing then why
would you go to hell people that I was
like some [ __ ] but some people are
like that the number of times I've heard
girls talking about you know hollered at
me the other day who is that guy creep
yo for real how which ending he just
loving both about that [ __ ] girls do
that but this girl did it even worse she
raised them up so she could try to shoot
him down and then brag about it [ __ ]
do we blocky Noble right so this is the
part where she kind of claims like yeah
Walter did this whole plan to separate
the two and he's like nah you come with
me she's going over there this is what
she claims so let's see what they say So
eventually like they pull up into we
pull up in front of the podcast
apartment and Myron's coming out of the
building and I get out of the car and
Walter leaves with my friend and took
her to like no
so
I'm with my room by myself so he we get
into his car and he drives us to like
this like
see see how she's trying to spin it as
if she didn't know that was gonna happen
let's pull up the text message
conversation listen uh the club closed
uh the club closed at 5am right and she
goes are you down to get food in 20.
right so she hits me up uh it says well
uh well just he's leaving in 20 what is
he okay cool is Walter gonna bring you
to Brickell and I can get you and she he
goes uh was it goes wall said he'll
bring me to Brickell
boom
I'll bring her there it doesn't first
off let me let me ask something God if
you are going somewhere with somebody
you don't say yeah I'll bring them there
you'll say we're coming
yeah well we're all coming whoa clearly
these are premeditated plans but she's
trying to make it sound like she got
ambushed with a separation
foreign
my two points was the hoodie and the
Listerine yeah because she got there and
she decided to get so comfortable she
changed out of her clothes and put on
his clothes I hate that I hate
everything about you but let me put
something with your name on there if you
don't get the [ __ ] out of here
you're in danger you're putting on your
potential attackers hoodie put on the
Ops hoodie what what is going on here
bro so she was cold and she found a
hoodie to have more clothes on
oh she actually changed clothes oh she
did I think I gave her some shorts or
some [ __ ] she said that herself she said
that herself she said after that she
went and changed back in her clothes she
did say that she changed she even
grabbed some of his shorts
bruv she said it I'm trying to leave
it let me put on my PJs I'm trying to
leave
where am I Blinky at I'm trying to leave
get out get out and so I'm like I have
my hands like on him where it's like I
don't want him like laying on me like
intimately so I'm just holding my hands
up and I'm like no no no this was about
like Max a minute long and I was wearing
like this shirt and it's like a very
loose shirt whatever and he basically
lifts up the shirt and made a comment
and then I was like I'm done I'm over
this like and I lifted up your shirt and
kind of looked at underneath it and
commented yeah yeah my chest because I
have I have piercings
I'm sorry you say what
I said I have piercing so he made a
comment on it oh okay and it was very
creepy it was so I I I I don't wanna
no it was not creepy she's mad because I
basically made a joke about her titties
being lopsided Whatever It Is What It
[ __ ] it is man
all right there you go Tada okay
okay
so we got to just add on to some of the
lives that she told and all the
mischaracterizations
maybe I don't know maybe I'm just
different maybe I'm weird I couldn't
imagine looking at somebody's naked body
and then just making a funny comment
like that knowing one how self-conscious
women traditionally are or how we all
are the same thing like if a dude showed
his dick for the first time let's say
you had a small thing last thing you
think a woman should be saying is like
damn that penis is so small how do you
think she's gonna take that or he's
gonna take that listen women are super
self-conscious about their titties okay
they don't like the way it sags they
don't like the way it's shaped because
the world keeps telling them stuff and a
loser like you gets in bed with a girl
okay and then says that [ __ ] that's a
loser move when you're sitting here
laughing and giggling about it sure you
don't like her but why would in the
moment usually be like damn your titties
are crooked who the [ __ ] talks like that
throughout this whole thing I've said
the way that they're doing this
narrative even though she said oh I
don't think he did a crime or whatever
listen the way you've said this story
the way that you guys are framed it the
fact that Ethan keeps implying it the
fact that most of the people the comet
said that's what he did we all
understand what you're framing okay you
can't say I didn't say you did that
crime but you're like oh yeah yeah uh
well you know he did grab a knife and
then put inside me oh so are you stabbed
him no no I'm not saying you stabbed me
I'm just saying like you know I was
uncomfortable what
okay we all understand the implication
of what is being said that doesn't mean
that this dude's not a loser okay that
doesn't mean that this dude is not a
goober okay who doesn't know how to act
with people who gets snakes see
man who does that losers that's what it
comes down to he had no interest
recording her was hey all the power to
you don't have to do that okay
my point being is like we know these
dudes are losers that's okay you're
allowed to that's legal and you could
feel any type of way that you want about
that but to come on and frame things
with lives like that if you just come
out like man this guy was a loser he
made a comment when I need everybody
would have been cool with it
but you have to lie and do all this
extra stuff and I gotta look at you
crazy now it's gymnastics bro and that's
the thing you could have just said that
you could have just said that and even
if he said that
he said that he made a comment about
your boobies
was it worth all the LIE
all of that now you just look stupid
Danielle
yeah I'm saying your name because
[ __ ] have to know your name the
same way you try to frame a [ __ ]
like that people need to know who the
[ __ ] you are yeah just so they know that
you're a piece of [ __ ] you want to frame
them as a piece of [ __ ] but the bigger
the biggest piece of [ __ ] in this story
is you it's you it's you my girl you and
Ethan Klein who didn't even say anything
like what you were a big ass loser
that's you you want a frame is that a
big loser it's all you all you yup the
the whole story
could have been easily avoided by both
parties it's like guys it doesn't cost
you anything to be half decent to the
people you're gonna [ __ ] cost you
nothing why would they they don't
respect these people that's what I'm
trying to say like who talks like that
to human beings doesn't give a [ __ ] now
he's trying to say this because I know
every dude would get so upset if a woman
saw a nigga's dick for the first time
and say some [ __ ] like that but you guys
gonna say like that about the women's
private parts what's wrong with you guys
listen he talks like that to his co-host
right but you wonder why some of these
ladies go out and get these titty jobs
and do those other stuff it's because
y'all be out here mocking the way that
they they look physically in terms of
like their naked body you got women
doing labioplasties and shaving off all
parts was like oh my God there's too
much who cares
we want them to lose our sensitivities
like it's so stupid I don't know it
costs you nothing to just be a tad bit
considerate I'm not asking you to simp
or to White Knight but don't look at
somebody's naked body and then say some
crazy stuff that's wild to me bro why
don't you trying to contribute to like
people's bad self-esteem by saying some
[ __ ] like that you know what I mean yeah
the things they can't even
to me that's that's the part where he's
a complete loser in that regards but you
knew that already but we knew that you
knew that already you went there to
frame here because you thought he was a
loser now you're you're just astonished
when he's a loser come on now B you're
you're let me write something you people
said well she's 19 and you know what I
find not so fascinating about people who
say that [ __ ] it's like they always pick
and choose on people or adults or not
yep oh yeah if a 19 year old gets the
only fans
yeah go go ham you are mature enough
yeah to post yourself nagging all over
the way yes girl yeah you could go to
the military but you don't know better
when it comes to [ __ ] people yeah
go to the military student loans don't
matter yeah it's all gay oh yeah you can
take students long and that's no you're
younger than that and that's how you
know the whole age thing is just the
front yeah to be able to control this
situation because even if they were the
same age guess what a man you're still
more liable because you're a beaker
you're stronger and so therefore they
think you go it's always the man's
responsibility to be a [ __ ] mind
reader to assume the girl's mental
well-being to do all this other stuff
people are saying crazy stuff like he
gave her alcohol he did not give her
alcohol any point she went to the club
decided to have some drinks on her own
okay then she gets to his apartment all
right apparently he's Lucid enough to
remember this whole [ __ ] story opens
his friend says yo you got white claw
he's like yeah he's like can I have
something you want but don't tell
anybody how is that him offering you
went through his stuff to ask if you
could have some I don't know it's just
at every turn when he comes to these
stories everybody who defends the woman
literally gives her zero accountability
throughout the whole thing and expects a
man to have 150 percent
agency he has all the power he has all
the ability it's like are women use
these helpless creatures who are [ __ ]
useless until they're 25. is that what
we're trying to say here then how is she
able to call the Uber at the end of the
night when she the guy said okay you can
leave
it's better than that any time of the
night but whatever
it's really important this whole thing
because people keep mentioning the Apes
listen I think young women are annoying
as [ __ ] I never want to be around them
if they come around me I'm always
disgusted I don't like being around them
okay there's nothing appealing
but I also accept that they're adults
they may not be the most mature adults
but they are adults and if they want to
go and [ __ ] whoever they want that's it
and if you've got a problem with that
that's cool you can say they're not
mature enough they're prefrontal cortex
doesn't develop to the 25 fine
but then change and you have to keep the
same energy
for changing the age of consent to 25 in
all categories they can't vote till
they're 25 they can't do only fans until
25 they can take student loans for 25.
they're really not an adult and they
can't do anything with their parents
without their parents consent until
they're 25. that's the theme that we
have to sit if you want to say they're
too [ __ ] baby to choose who they want
to [ __ ] then you have to keep it
consistent across the board until you do
that I don't want to hear nothing about
that go ahead no we're good all right
let's